if we don't heed the lessons of the
1970s which were bad lessons and the
lessons before Leaphart of this decade
then we will find ourselves in trouble
and that is no matter what happens
during a period like this it is critical
to preserve the quality of life the
schools have to continue to improve
crime cannot go up and ideally it has to
go down the parks have to remain clean
and well maintained our cultural
institutions need to be supported
housing stock has to be maintained and
people have to be able to afford to live
here where you maintain the quality of
life yes we will all suffer somewhat
during a period of like this I think the
mayor is the single best person in the
world to manage through a crisis like
this because he's very good at finding
ways of doing more with less and
understands fundamentally that what this
all is about is maintaining and
enhancing that quality of life so that
when the recovery does occur we haven't
set ourselves back so far they will
spend decades trying to dig ourselves
out of the hole
you